House of the Dragon is a Game of Thrones prequel
show that is confirmed by HBO’s president
to air in 2022.
The show is currently casting roles, filming
begins in January 2021 and the show will air
in 2022.
It is based on George RR Martin’s book Fire
And Blood volume 1 and on Martin’s yet unfinished
Fire And Blood volume 2 book.
Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan Condal will serve
as showrunners and executive producers. George
R. R. Martin will also serve as executive
producer.
HBO’s spinoff, House of the Dragon, has
also recently announced its first casting
via Entertainment Weekly.
It is confirmed that English actor Paddy Considine
will star in the prequel as King Viserys I
Targaryen, the man who began the Targaryen
civil war known as the Dance of the Dragons,
although he certainly never meant for it to
come to that. This makes him officially the
first actor cast in the new show, set to land
in 2022.
The news comes complete with a casting description,
which sounds intriguing by itself:
“King Viserys Targaryen is chosen by the
lords of Westeros to succeed the Old King,
Jaehaerys Targaryen, at the Great Council
at Harrenhal. A warm, kind, and decent man,
Viserys only wishes to carry forward his grandfather’s
legacy. But good men do not necessarily make
for great kings.”
Viserys I Targaryen was the fifth Targaryen
king to sit the Iron Throne, ruling from 103
AC to 129 AC. He succeeded his grandfather,
the Old King Jaehaerys I. Viserys continued
the prosperous peace and legacy of his grandsire,
but the seeds for the civil war known as the
Dance of the Dragons that would much later
engulf the realm were inadvertently sown in
his reign.
Viserys was a dragon rider who rode Balerion
until the dragon died of old age. Viserys
never bonded with another dragon after Balerion's
death.
Indeed, King Viserys was known as a decent
guy and ruled Westeros during a largely peaceful
time when the Targaryen dynasty was at its
height. But a succession crisis after his
death would tear everything apart. To make
a very long story short, after Viserys dies,
there’s a bitter battle between his daughter
Rhaenyra Targaryen, who he had named to be
his heir, and his son Aegon Targaryen, Rhaenyra’s
half-brother born of another wife after Rhaenyra’s
mother had died. This was the Dance of the
Dragons, and it’s what House of the Dragon
will cover.
The Dance of the Dragons was the most devastating
war in the history of the Seven Kingdoms.
A war of succession between Aegon II and his
half-sister Rhaenyra over their father Viserys
I's throne.
By the end of the reign of King Viserys I
Targaryen, twenty dragons were alive. The
majority of these died during the civil war
called the Dance of the Dragons, which began
in 129 AC and lasted until mid 131 AC.
EW also confirms some other roles HBO is currently
casting:
—Princess Rhaenyra Targaryen: “King Viserys’
chosen heir, a dragon rider who grew up expecting
to become the first ruling Queen of Westeros.”
—Queen Alicent Hightower: “Viserys’
ambitious second wife and Rhaenyra’s stepmother,
who had three children of her own with the
king.”
—Aegon II Targaryen: “Princess Rhaenyra’s
younger half-brother who challenges Rhaenyra’s
claim to the throne, igniting a civil war.”
—Prince Daemon Targaryen: “Rhaenyra’s
uncle, an experienced warrior.”
It is now officially confirmed that Game of
Thrones prequel series, House of the Dragon,
will start with a build-up towards the Dance
of the Dragons and early seasons will cover
the prelude to and the actual Targaryen civil
war.
Later seasons however will be based on George
RR Martin's yet unfinished Fire And Blood
volume 2 book.
Let me remind you that Game of Thrones prequel
show is based on the book Fire And Blood book
which has 2 parts, volume 1 as well as the
yet unfinished volume 2.
The released Fire And Blood volume 1 book
covers the history of House Targaryen from
the Targaryen conquest, Aegon's Conquest of
the Seven Kingdoms of Westeros to the dying
of the dragons, the great civil war known
as the Dance of the Dragons and its aftermath,
the reign of Rhaenyra's young son Aegon lll.
The yet unreleased Fire And Blood volume 2
book will continue with the reign of Aegon
lll known as the Dragonsbane for the last
dragon died during his reign and will continue
with his sons after him including the famous
Daeron the Young Dragon, a 14-year-old Alexander
the Great figure who conquered what Aegon
the Conqueror failed to conquer - Dorne but
died in the process. Then it will continue
with King Baelor the Blessed and a brief reign
of Viserys ll. After that, Aegon lV known
as Aegon the Unworthy who's reign is a build-up
towards the Blackfyre rebellions when he legitimized
his bastard son Daemon, giving him Blackfyre
surname after he gave him the famous Targaryen
sword Blackfyre. When Aegon lV dies, his Targaryen
children have to face a rebellion and defend
the realm from the Blackfyres.
Final seasons of Game of Thrones prequel show
could include all of that and more - Roberts
Rebellion, the fall of the great Targaryen
dynasty as Fire And Blood volume 2 book will
cover as well.
How do I know the second part of the Targaryen
history will cover all that? Because George
RR Martin himself revealed it.
If
the show
was
only based on Fire And Blood volume 1 book,
then it would have few seasons because the
show will only cover second part of Fire And
Blood volume 1.
Confirmed by casting news to start with the
build-up to the Dance of the Dragons, and
of course, the Targaryen civil war itself,
which means the show will only use about 370
pages out of Fire And Blood volume 1 book.
In comparison, the book material Game of Thrones
show used was 4000 pages with the additional
summary from George RR Martin about the ending.
If this prequel show is going to run 10 or
more seasons as many expect and as HBO and
George RR Martin themselves probably want
just as they wanted Game of Thrones, or if
at least this show is going to run as long
as Game of Thrones did, then the show will
have to use more than 370 pages of book material
and will likely cover Fire And Blood volume
2 book, to what extent though we do not know
for sure.
It could go on to cover Aegon lll’s reign
and his son’s Daeron ll reign, a character
who was based on Alexander the Great, Daeron
conquered what Aegon the Conqueror failed
to conquer - Dorne.
It could also go on to Aegon IV’s reign
and cover the Blackfyre Rebellions as it is
also something fans are eager to know more
of and watch, or it could go all the way to
the fall of the Targaryen dynasty as the book
Fire And Blood volume 2 will, and cover Robert’s
Rebellion itself.
This makes the show even more mysterious and
leaves us in dark because we don't have Fire
And Blood volume 2 nor will it be released
anytime soon with George RR Martin currently
focusing on The Winds of Winter.
This would leave us spoiler-free for the later
seasons of House of the Dragon, although we
don't have much spoilers going into the show
in the first place really, or at least not
from the books.
Some would think that you could just read
the book Fire & Blood to know what will happen
in the show based on that very same book but
that's far from the truth. Why?
Because let me remind you that Fire And Blood
is not a non-conventional novel, it is an
imaginary history book of House Targaryen
written by George R. R. Martin from the perspective
of Archmaester Gyldayn who wrote it many decades
after the events took place, and according
to George RR Martin himself, not very accurate
at that.
Because while Fire And blood book was written
by George RR Martin, it wasn't written from
him as facts, but rather through the perspective
of the Citadel's Archmaester Gyldayn who gathered
all the info and as many different sources
as he could and used it to write a book about
the Targaryen history. Some info is fake,
some info is true, some info is semi-true.
No one will know for a fact what was happening
in real history until the House of the Dragon
airs
in 2022.
The show unlike the book will contain truth,
it will depict what actually happened, not
the changed history, fake or semi-true, not
what might or might not have happened.
It is confirmed that the House of the Dragon
show will start with prelude to the Targaryen
civil war but it is and will be for a long
time unknown to what extent will the show
go.
Many thought the show was going to start with
Aegon’s Conquest and go to the Dance of
the Dragons.
There is roughly the same time difference
between that and between the Dance of the
Dragons and the end of the Targaryen dynasty
that ended with Robert’s Rebellion.
There is a high possibility that in the final
season of the Targaryen prequel series we
could see Robert’s rebellion and finally
get answers to all the questions we have.
Daenerys being born and smuggled into exile
to escape Robert’s wrath could be the final
scene of the House of the Dragon show.
For the end, I just want to share with you
guys that the same source that sent me seasons
7 and 8 leaks (that turned out 100% true)
has recently sent me leaked outline for the
first season of House of the Dragon.
I'm not sure if I should share it with you
or not, so let me know in the comment section
down below.
Do you guys want to stay spoiler-free because
this does seem to be legit or do you want
me to make videos about it, covering every
and each episode leaked outline of the Game
of Thrones prequel show season 1? Let me know!
Thank you so much for watching, I hope you
enjoyed this video and if you did please give
it a big thumbs up and I hope to see you in
the next one. Peace!